j'ai perdu mon père en novembre dernier
il est mort seul pour les personnes
vulnérables
les visites de leurs proches sont
essentiels
[Musique]
quand on se renseigne comme on fait tous
sur le site de l'hôpital on lit les
consignes on signe assez précises
concernant les visites des personnes
hospitalisées mais sauf qu'en fait ça
n'est plus valable ça ne s'applique plus
mes parents sont vaccinés tous les deux
depuis le mois de mars
mais en fait non ça n'a pas d'importance
parce que apparemment c'est pas c'est
pas fiable
[Musique]
j'ai perdu mon père en novembre dernier
il a passé les 17 jours de son
hospitalisation dans la solitude absolue
et il est mort celle nous avons été
privés d'un dernier adieu à sa dépouille
[Musique]
toutes les recommandations officielles
depuis un an préconise de laisser les
visites aux proches surtout lorsque la
situation se dégrade et surtout en cas
de fin de vie et depuis un an on assiste
vraiment à de graves dérives
pour moi c'est une question d'humanité
on ne peut plus laisser des personnes
partir seul
les familles ont le droit de pouvoir
visiter les personnes malades dans les
conditions humaines
[Musique]
nous avons reçu aujourd'hui et plus de
8000 témoignages et 45000 personnes ont
signé notre pétition et on a tous les
jours des personnes totalement dévastée
par par ces drames dont la plupart des
cas les équipes soignantes et les
directeurs se montrent compréhensifs ils
font rentrer les familles surtout à l
approche de la mort mais malheureusement
dans record du nombre de cas de services
qui restent permet aux proches
on a d'impunité des gestionnaires qui
peuvent aujourd'hui encore restreindre
les visites en toute impunité
[Musique]
les personnes âgées vulnérables ont
besoin avant tout d'une manie t elles
ont besoin de la visite de leurs proches
c'est en fait c'est la seule chose dont
elles ont vraiment besoin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on vient un moment grave
les services se ferme à nouveau en
raison des circonstances
olivier ferrand affirme que des visites
doit être respectée mais sur le terrain
il n'y a rien aujourd'hui qui prend
treize établissements halal a piqué et
donc on appelle vraiment à une cohérence
entre le discours et les actes
[Musique]